just a short drive or flight from Vegas
Anaheim California is the perfect
holiday destination Jillian gives us a
tour of the Anaheim packing house thanks
to the sponsors of this segment visit
Anaheim check it out
[Music]
well if you hop on a quick flight or
take the drive from Vegas to Anaheim
there are so many things to see and do
and I'm here with the president and CEO
of visit Anaheim and you're probably
wondering why we have these drinks at
Jay Burr thank you so much for having us
we're at one of my favorite places tell
us a little bit first about the Anaheim
packing house this is the Anaheim
packing house it was the original
sun-kissed packing house where actual
oranges were packed here and put on the
train to go throughout East we all were
in The Groves here in Orange County now
it is a great fantastic site for
visitors to come over 20 establishments
for great food great unique gifts it's
especially unique during the holiday
time because they really spin everything
towards the holiday time great time to
be there and experience one of these
from the packing house and Beyond
Anaheim transforms into a holiday
Wonderland a new tradition just started
recently and that is at Angel Stadium in
the parking lot they transformed the
entire parking lot into a lighted
drive-through light display fantastic to
really put you in the holiday spirit
even the Muk deck the halls with
fantastic decorations got to be South
Coast Plaza South Coast Plaza is a
premier shopping destination in the
entire world but at the holiday time
they really come alive they've got
everything from a I guess it's a
reindeer Carousel they've got different
Specialty Foods specialty shops all
throughout the the destination and it
truly is a shopping destination not just
a mall there's a lot to experience in
the area well we're really built for
this because it's so many people take
advantage of every holiday the different
theme parks the different hotels the
different entertainment areas such as
this that it really lends itself to it's
great during the Halloween time it's
great during the holiday time it's great
during every season they really look
forward to the entire destination into
changing things up specifically for That
season so whether it's decoration
whether it's themed rooms whether it's
themed Foods we love a holiday here in
Anaheim in Vegas to Anna Heim is a quick
trip you know we're only a few short
hours from Las Vegas Las Vegas is one of
our top feeder markets in Anaheim so
lots of families in Las Vegas love to
come out here it's a great place to come
if you can't come at the holiday time in
2023 we're going to have even more new
things going on it's the 100th
anniversary of Disney as a company so
you know they'll have some things up
their sleeve great time to come to
Anaheim well Jay I feel like to
experience all of these things you told
us about you'd have to stay in Anaheim
for a few days you have a few hotels you
recommend checking out we've got great
hotels here and of every category we're
very blessed the last couple years we've
opened up three new deluxe four Diamond
hotels you got your
selection from the very highest end down
to the budget hotel whatever you're
looking for you can find it here I think
we
let's do it I think it's time to eat and
drinks let's go inside
and now is your chance to win a
two-night stay at the JW Marriott
Anaheim Resort tickets to a hockey game
at the Honda Center and a four pack of
tickets to Knott's Berry Farm just head
to 8newsnow.com and enter today's
keyword family Las Vegas now we'll be
right back
[Music]